انهى مجلس الحرب الاسرائيلي اجتماعا امتد
حتى الساعه الثانيه بعد منتصف الليله
الماضيه ووصفت المعلومات التي تسربت من
الاجتماع بانه او وصفته بانه كان قاسيا
وصعبا وشهد توترا محتدما بين اركانه حيث
بحث صفقه جديده يتم التفاوض بشانها مع
الوسطاء وفق ما نقلته القناه الثانيه ع في
التلفزات الاسرائيليه وذكرت الاذاعه
الاسرائيليه ان الاجتماع شهد حاله من
الغضب بين الوزراء بعد ما غادره وزير
الدفاع يو اف جالانت ورئيس الاركان هيرتس
هاليفي في منتصفه واشارت الاذاعه الى ان
المجلس سيعقد اجتماعا اخر الاسبوع القادم
واعقب هذا الاجتماع اجتماع للطاقم الوزاري
المصغر الذي يضم وزراء يمثلون كافه احزاب
الائتلاف وكان نتنياهو دع الى الاجتماعين
على خلفيه العرض الذي قدمته حركه حماس
ابرام صفقه لتبادل
الاسرى معنا من رام الله مدير مكتب
الجزيره وليد العمري اهلا بك وليد كيف
تتلقى في اسرائيل انتقادات الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن للاداء الاسرائيلي
والسلوك الاسرائيلي في الحرب على غزه لا
سما وانها تقاطعت مع اجتماع مجلس الحرب
الذي وصف بالقاس والصعب وغادره وزير
الدفاع ورئيس
الاركان تصريح الرئيس الامريكي تؤكد ما
خرج عن المباحثات التي اجراها وزير
الخارجيه بلينكن والقراءات التي تلتها من
ان زياره بلينكن قد كشفت عن عمق الازمه
والخلاف بين الاداره الامريكيه ونتنياهو
وحكومته وواضح بان الاداره الامريكيه فعلا
تحاول ممارسه الضغط وهو ما كان وزير
الخارجيه بلينكن قد طلبه من نتنياهو ايضا
لكن نتنياهو خالف ذلك ولم يعد بتقديم
المساعدات او تسهيل دخولها وتجنيب
المدنيين ال ويلات الحرب تحديدا في منطقه
رفح لذلك ما يتلقاه الاسرائيليون هنا
ويقرا هو بان زياره بلينكن قد كشفت عن عمق
الخلاف وعمق الازمه الثقه بين الرئيس
بايدن وبين رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
نتنياهو على وجه الخصوص وما يدلل على ذلك
ايضا بان وزير الخارجيه بلينكن بالامس كان
قد تراجع
عن قرار بزياره معبر كرم ابو سالم بعد ان
امتنعت ورفضت الحك او رفض نتنياهو تحديدا
منع المتظاهرين اليمينيين من التواجد هناك
لمنع دخول المساعدات الى غزه وتكشف لاحقا
بان هناك امر صادر من وزير الشرطه الى
الشرطه بان لا تتصدى لهم وان تبقيهم
يمنعون هذه السيارات المحمله بالمساعدات
من الدخول الموضوع الثاني الذي كان محل
خلاف وهو ايضا ما يشير اليه سواء من خلال
زياره بلينكن او تصريحات الرئيس الامريكي
هي ان الولايات المتحده تحاول ان تثني
اسرائيل عن توسيع حربها في قطاع غزه في
الجنوب تحديدا لتمتد من خان يونس الى
منطقه رفح وذلك حمايه للنازحين
الفلسطينيين الذين يحتشدون بمئات الاف في
هذه المنطقه ونتنياهو ذهب في مؤتمره
الصحفي الى التاكيد بانه اوعز للجيش بان
يبدا عمليه يستعد لبدء عمليه عسكريه في
منطقه رفح هذا المواضيع مجتمعه كانت ايضا
سبب الجلسه الصعبه والقاسيه التي كانت في
مجلس الحرب تحديدا الليله الماضيه والتي
اعقبت اجتماع الكابينت الطاقم الوزاري
الامني السياسي المصغر وقد امتدت جلسه
مجلس الحرب الى ما بعد منتصف الليل حتى
الساعه الثانيه بعد منتصف الليل وانسحب
منها وزير الدفاع رئيس رئيس هيئه الاركان
لكن انسحب ايضا بعد خلاف على خطه قدماها
من اجل ان تبدا اسرائيل بادخال مساعدات
باشراف الجيش وتسليمها مباشره الى التجار
في قطاع غزه او الى هيئه في شمالي القطاع
فقط من خلال معابر كارني المنطار الشرقي
لقطاع غزه وكذلك معبر ايرز وهو ما رفضه
نتنياهو هذا التوتر زاد اليه ايضا الموقف
الذي يتبناه الوزير جانس والوزير في مجلس
الحرب ايزنكوت والذان يدفعان باتجاه ان
تكون اسرائيل مرنه بالتعامل مع المقترحات
المطروحه من اجل ابرام صفقه لتبادل الاسرى
بعد ان اتخذت الموقف الذي اعلنه نتنياهو
وتتحدث عن انها لن لا تقدم في هذا المجال
شكرا جزيلا لك وليد العمري مدير مكتبنا من
رام الله